of course as we talk about memorial day
and the weekend it is the unofficial
kickoff to summer so certainly a good
time to dust off the old grill
but how can you cook up some goodness
without breaking the bank earlier this
week i went to the barbecue expert to
find out
all right we're here in the kitchen of
soul belly in the arts district and i've
got celebrity chef bruce with me and we
are talking memorial day barbecue you
know we've been talking a lot on the
news about how food prices are going up
so we want to stretch that dollar what's
a good thing to do everybody wants some
sort of meat what do you suggest yeah i
i mean you know
us and i think every restaurant in the
country right now especially is battling
with pricing issues right cost issues
and even even the home user is it's even
a worse situation
so you know what we
do here is we try to kind of balance the
proteins that we use so obviously we
have our brisket
which is
very expensive right now but
very well worth it right yeah that looks
absolutely succulent divine
jiggly meat jiggly meat okay and then we
have you know rib pork ribs pork ferrous
which are also expensive but then we
have
pork shoulder you know pulled pork and
what i would suggest and and full pork
is really easy and forgiving you know
this is a pork shoulder we smoked for
about 10 hours got it um and even if you
didn't pay the care and attention to it
that we do it'll still come out really
good okay so you can buy the pork
shoulder at the store obviously or you
could just come here and buy the whole
thing typically yeah exactly typically
they'll call it the pork shoulder pork
butt okay it's not from the butt
it's actually the shoulder
but um
you know you want to get a bone-in
pork shoulder because without the bone
the bone is kind of helps keep it
together keeps it moist and juicy it
doesn't need to be smoked i mean you can
do a nice roasted pork shoulder okay uh
we actually sell our pork rub here at so
belly you can come by and get it or you
can use your favorite seasoning mix and
what i like to do is just kind of break
up that fat cap on top because you want
all that fat in there you know we rub
them in with our rub and then we smoke
them
and when they get a nice bark on the
outside and that fat cat starts to split
we'll wrap it with um
with the aluminum foil and you can see
it just like
literally just comes apart this is our
carolina red sauce it's a vinegar based
sauce a lot of chili a lot of black
pepper so now you can buy sauce pretty
much anywhere you can make your own but
you guys also sell one we do makes it
easy yeah we sell our carolina sauce
we sell our sweet and spicy sauces as
well i kind of do want to try it you
should i want you to try it
it's succulent right
legit it was delicious so it is time to
plan ahead for the weekend you got to
look for the deals and if you do plan on
skipping the grocer all together of
course you can pick it all up at soul
belly just keep in mind they are closed
on monday
chef back on monday speaking of with
some cost saving tips for those all
important side dishes you gotta have it
all including